Remember the libraries we loaded earlier
to do cool things like draw on the map,
we've been saving the best library for
last, the Places Library.
The functionality in the Google Places
Library enables your application to
search for places, like establishments,
geographic locations or
prominent points of interest
contained within a defined area,
such as the bounds of a map or
around a fixed point.
You'll be able to access a crazy amount
of data on your favorite McDonald's,
nail salons, bars, police stations.
>> That sounds like a typical night out,
eh Emily.
>> Anyway,
we'll cover details like that later.
Our first usage of this
data is much simpler.
So far we've been typing in addresses or
locations in order to search for
nearby listings in our site.
What if we didn't want to have
to write out the whole thing?
>> Google's Place's Library has
the places auto complete functionality
which allows the user to get
back probable results with
each keystroke while
entering a location.
So they can find what they're looking
for faster and more accurately.
Essentially, we know what the user is
typing before they finish typing it.
>> Let's go back into our code and
update both of these text input
areas to use autocomplete.
The first thing that we have to
do is include another library,
the Place's Library.
This will allow us to use autocomplete
and also other features of Places later.
So, we'll define two
new places autocomplete
instances within our initialize function
and bind them to our two input boxes.
At the simplest level,
these will predict what the user
is typing with each keystroke, and
supply the most likely options in
a pick list below the input box.
We can also add more options to these.
In addition to specifying which text
input to execute autocomplete on,
we can add bounds, which is a lot long
area to bias the results towards.
This won't restrict the results, but
it will favor items within those bounds.
We can also add a types restriction,
which will restrict the types of
places we get back to for example,
addresses for only precise addresses or
establishments for only business.
And we can add a component
restriction to restrict the results
to within a certain country.
Let's try biasing the zoom
to area autocomplete
to within the bounds of the map.
Let's test it out.
This makes it much easier for the user
and also makes it much more likely that
the Geocoder or Distance Matrix Service
actually finds a location.
Let's look at the difference
between the zoom to area one and
the Distance Matrix one.
Right now they're both supplying options
for New York City, that's because we
biased the zoom to area one to
within the bounds of the map.
But also because even if
you don't set any bounds,
the API will attempt to
detect your location and
it'll automatically bias
the results to that location.
Thus this one is trying to find me
a place in New York because I'm
currently in New York.
Let's change the bounds of the map and
see if it makes a difference.
Okay, I've changed the bounds of the map
so that we're looking at Detroit.
Now, the autocomplete which I
bound to the area of the map
is actually looking for
places in Detroit.
Whereas the one where I
didn't bind it to anything,
still knows that I'm in New York City.
Pretty neat.
If I don't want any bias, I can also
specify the bounds of the whole world.
Let's take a break before continuing
to find out how fast autocomplete
really is.